Tournament is on I was reading off a
youtube comment to those who are tuned
into the stream and what do you know the
tournament started I gotta close out of
that here we go I have a center my
opponents ready to kill my queen and I'm
ready to kill their Knight
oh he's got a run home now this bishop
is in rough shape I don't care about
taking him I'd much rather take this
pond with a knight a juicy Knight maybe
I'll kill that Bishop I don't really
take that pawn it's probably crazy yeah
I get to get into these dark squares
we're really gonna take that come on why
wasn't that moving my opponent is flying
they can't they can't um what can't they
do I want my knight here
I want my knight to be around why am I
not moving oh I have a fork oh my
goodness ah man there was a much better
way to get this I don't make clean here
on the rook that clean Knight check
right here might be good oh my goodness
let my opponent get away or am I getting
them in a fork finally god I'm in a fork
let's trade I want to take with the pond
I want to restrict them let's do this
next tricky Knight oh my goodness 10
seconds
the knight is trapped really take that
oh my goodness time situation you know
that's not good
oh my goodness I wanna time I was
holding my breath oh man I don't even
know I I couldn't even hire 0.5 seconds
first okay hey you go no hang on
Wow my heart is pounding my heart is in
my throat oh my goodness hey hey uh-oh
sacrifices here I feel it
okay now not anymore I'm on this pond
twice yeah you definitely don't want to
have that as your first game oh my
goodness
so dangerous Tom push clean all the way
back let's do this I'm on this I'm
opening up the diagonal I need to get
developed let's go here with the tempo
the pawn is pinned the queen is kind of
like oh she's dead well not really
it's not free clean not a free queen oh
I'm on that rook how long was that there
for how long was that there for I
challenge the knight right away he jumps
in he's getting active okay I get to
hang out of that pond time fortunately
is not as much an issue on this one is
it nope
all right I have to uh okay now now I
could just do what now I could just get
out of the way and a run keep going
let's go check the bishop is cooked
let's cut off the King hang on to that
pun check and then pick him up then it
makes life easier come on get this king
up get the king up keep marching back to
turn with her down that time 20 John
Madden slow down 20 20 18
oh okay I'm gonna chase that night away
is to find a new home he's close to dead
actually he is dead pretty much pretty
much I did this so that if my punished
challenged my rook is protected I could
I could I could I reinforced that throw
another one in Bishop check should I
really be afraid of that not think so I
don't think so if Bishop check I
actually move my king that way the Queen
is still restricted it's exactly I'm
talking about so now the queen is
tethered to the defensive a piece not a
good position to be in that's why I
chose now to capture there the giant
tsunami of pawns tsunami of pawns now
the knight is dead probably take someone
out with them recapture with the night
my queen has no business really being on
d5 the knight is better placed in the
center 33 seconds to less than 30
seconds okay let's just take that one
out maybe I should have considered that
pod push first get completed to my
development let's show this age pond
down open up the age file okay I have
the dark square and unopposed to dark
square Bishop how can I make that work
power push pawn okay I definitely know
definitely right now he'd be pushing G
files opened up the night might jump in
here I'd back up and still keep the
knight box-style he's he's under control
Queen d3 to complete my development and
tack the night they are not resigning
they are down on time forty twenty
eighteen oh my goodness that first oh oh
they didn't date what would they must
have declined something I got another
game in what happened there I can't go
back and check what a wonderful pun what
a wonderful check checking pun that was
what you call it checking fun oh that's
what you call Mouse Lib Forex
and take with this pun get that piece
right back
give me that piece right back
LightSquared bishop needs to come out
and play come out and play okay this is
a trouble whoa
the Knights pinned and now this move is
annoying the Queen would probably want
to go to one of these - they Castle and
then no okay let's put pressure on this
I should have done in a different way
let's get this little pond going the
little pun don't mistake that for
another fun don't mistake that for the
big pot now pond push is probably a good
idea on the rook that's me I needed that
I needed that 170 oh my goodness my
throw
70/30 a lot of time left 22 minutes 70
points what is going on okay
caro-kann exchange means what it means
that no one will die soon it's game on
I'm okay with that
give me the opened uh the open wat the
open G file Castle queenside now King
side throw my king in the corner of rook
to g8 safe over here it's too Airy over
on the Queen side I don't care about
that night
he's not bothering me is he we've done
two nights redundant nights this is
gonna be smashed open now g3 and then
game over very soon get that clean out
of there
why am I not moving oh my goodness why
am I not moving just move oh my goodness
I wasn't moving there
I hate what that happens oh yeah tell
you hey when you just you want to move
but you don't know what to move whoa
right here attacked at night and my
queen wants to get in the corner I'm
gonna throw my clean in the corner clean
in the corner clean in the corner uh-oh
this is dangerous
Nate one two three that's me
me one was calculating the bishop check
bishop check at g3 and then made on f2
stuff 8840 Mart oh I mean if I got
paired up with the top guy I mean I'm
not even close 88 238 Wow okay I have a
center this is like Kings gambit put a
very very very good version of it a very
rapid development good center and f7
which I should have been piling up on
right away as soon as that rook left I
should have pinpointed that maybe even
taking right away and somehow getting
the Queen on the diagonal are following
up with the knight check discovered
tricks are in the air I want to smash up
in this pond just feels right mate
threat actually soon mate threats qui g5
it would have been made if the Queen
recaptured but there would have been
discovered check after the King played
to G 888 it's fifty two forty thirty
thirty a lot of 30s 20 minutes remaining
okay here we go oh oh oh oh they might
wanna move my opponent moved I thought I
was gonna get a quick win okay that's a
that's a pretty tame tain move to be
going forward with there alright here we
go
tricky tricky tricky tricky ness
trickiness h2o i like my bishop too much
I like him way too much he's way too
excited now about this position way too
excited take that pawn I'm gonna be able
to castle probably a more effective way
to do this okay here we go hit the Queen
and look for look for me over here
actually this is a problem isn't it I
guess I can I have this knight boxed out
bishop here
it's not working looks like it's
effective is that Queen Queen's trapped
that's good no she's not
she wasn't trapped
false alarm let's retreat keep things
closed over here at night bet he's gonna
jump into this square that's picking up
some stuff probably just gonna give that
up aren't they hey am i clean already
no I'm I lied I don't know where I got
want to go let's just do that open stuff
up okay now this is all the bishops
there hit the knight and now hit this
pawn tricky Forex oh my goodness that's
close to mate all the Knights dead my
fears are gone as soon as the knight is
dead hang on there was mate threats
there if I wasn't careful
tap bishop was such a monster he was
such a monster that dark square bishop
18 minutes remaining I already played
this guy is this the same opening oh oh
my goodness I don't know Queen check I'm
alright could block with my bishop now I
sniffed that one out whoa I didn't stiff
that one out bishop here okay just take
this pawn
okay I got to work with this oh I'm on
f7
let's do this I want to take with my
bishop just drop back no matter what
night check should've did that uh this
bishops a pain gotta get rid of him
pawn push get that night out of there so
I could do Bishop check
I'm already here King is it safe over
here oh I have GA covered too probably
miss it
easy to miss easy to miss I don't want
to I didn't want my visual get in trap
rook g3 and then h3 hog push there might
be some skewer
oh how sneaky hey listening actually
it's okay
to throw this check in 22 seconds my
King feels like he could be trapped
it's a gonna be trapped I could drop
back here if it's pinned it's not being
pinned my king is safe the king is safe
on this dark square a lot of time oh I
had a check didn't I hear something
let's take this pawn throw to check just
for fun I want to get in b4 b4 before
it's too late before all it's me it's a
main threat what does that even do I
don't even know no it's pinned we're
both in pins may be a bad pre-move not
that one anything moves pretty move time
whoa that was a free ruck
trotty chop that that was a classic time
burner did you see that one fast pine
these have never suspect these look at
how fast you get a clean look at how
fast you get a queen back to tournament
they're down at time one twenty eight
eighty six seventy two seventy fifteen
and halfway point 95th halfway point
halfway point here halfway no I don't
want to deal with that give it no Smiths
more gambit the Knights gonna jump in
here I'm ok with that pump push I could
take and get away with it can't I know I
hear yes I can no I can't
oh yeah I could do this I could capture
my bishop if you like that little grunt
right there did you like that little
grunt that happens from time to time
let's make sure my queen could breathe
my queen needs to breathe she was
suffocating right there Oh bishop takes
it's probably working to reinforce this
part is probably just gonna fall who
cares about him
no I care about him cares about him I
care about him after all he is a tough
guy he's also passed he's a tough guy
and he's a passed fun here's the plan
okay I was gonna meet pom push with this
if there is some tricky stuff lining up
for me Queen block I might have done
this
tricky Knights maybe anchor point and
flight square anchor point in flight
square that just seems way too right
attack the rook with tempo
alright tricky stuff now nf2 very tricky
stuff family forks family family forks
ok Queen takes pawn push very dangerous
capture here feels like
what oh my goodness I thought my time
was down it's my opponents I saw I saw a
triple zeros I thought it was my time
148 110 106 90 13 minutes 32 seconds
one man's pond one man's pond the Kings
gambit when do I ever play this actually
I've played it a few times in this
tournament a few times okay
rapid development if if you don't hang
on to that pond white just turns out
with a fantastic game what am I even
doing with c3 all right
I have Queen c4 stuff and Queen B 5
let's do this and grab a pond run away
grab a pond there run away 95 Queen d5
keep my Queens central pins Bishop takes
Knight to take with the pond got a piece
it's still run white my queen my queen
is there to defend my rook keep my
structure as is it's double up same
story this is a problem this is a big
problem and you know what else is a
problem Bishop here stop that right now
maybe that would have been a problem I
don't know Knights pinned this next they
takes bishop we got me attack baton
pieces that's main I've determined that
was fairly quick 148 126 110 12 minutes
remaining
I think I've played this one before this
guy 12 minutes that's maybe six schemes
Oh a quick resigner
what a boost 148 136 110 110 hang on
AGM this guy flies I think I okay I'm
looking to get some structural damage my
opponent is preventing that really take
that
my nights at monster isn't he all my
piece is working and then do what and
then do what
okay I'm gonna attack that night and
then get that dark square Bishop and oh
this is dangerous isn't it
oh that night was pinned anyhow that
Bishop can't even be kicked there was a
better way to do things here there's a
fork it's definitely a fork there like
g3o by capturing the wrong direction it
should still be good somehow I want to
keep my clean can I keep my clean not
really my rook
I'm gonna sack there I actually have
that covered 15 seconds hang on to that
pun oh that's me
oh man that's exactly what I needed 168
156 130 130 128
wow what a tight tournament oh I should
have I should just throw my clean out
there sooner I was trying to get fancy
thinking oh when they block I'll attack
their night with my pond so much for
that so much for that so much for the
bishop he's gone just like that
don't blink whatever you do never blink
never didn't even have time to blink in
these tournaments no time to blink no
time queenside castle again all my piece
is working please get them all working
recapture maybe push that pod one day
let's go Knight stay central if the
knight moves I grab this pawn it's great
some weaknesses my knight wants to be
where c5 get there fast and actually do
this do that first secure my Knights
position now it can't be challenged I'm
actually hit minister promise you're
just taking it now the rook is gonna
move it's gonna be pinned I'm not gonna
take it of course you never never never
never soon as the King moves okay now
something was done about that and now we
take it we drop back that Knights
getting a little bit too scary so let's
get my king rumbling the king is
rumbling King takes pawn watch out for
the tricky Knight checks my king is
gonna hide well he's gonna gobble up a
piece right here keep my king on the
light square here no matter what
rooks are off my king is stable here no
matter what here no matter what light
squares function on light squares get my
pawn rolling he's passed still past the
bishop
you come to clean the Queenie is on the
scene
Bishop check watch out for stalemates
there's no stalemates bunch of pawns
that they could move maybe one two three
or something they're down on time back
to chairman one 188 176 one fifty one
fifty one forty eight one twenty nine
eight minutes remaining and a C for
English okay I could kick that guy
around giant con well can't take that
pound just yet tactics on h7 now it was
available I want to stop night here
queenside castle big trouble coming up
gained some more space I gave my
opponent that square this pawn going
just sack this just open lines up open
up the G file that's a free piece this
your pair these guys are spectators the
bishop and rook get my night working
Knight takes pawn keep my tricky Knight
give a rook check no matter what clean
over here and then discover tricks
double check maybe seems like a start
this is trouble finding pieces they
resigned back to term in 208 196 170 160
for 150 whew six minutes remaining six
minutes remaining
could I get a quick or win can I get a
quick d5 advance jump that gate that
night out of there right in this
diagonal
okay I want to cement that pond right
there c4 looks very appealing not the
ideal way to reinforce that but I think
actually pond push my bishop would have
been stuck am I trying too hard to hang
under this okay I got the LightSquared
bishop now let me see if I could get him
working oh that's a passed pawn stop
knight here
don't let keep my LightSquared bishop
right there keep him right there
he's not moving don't move that light
square bishop and everything's okay
everything is under control get rid of
this night maybe and then throw my queen
on d5 tricky Knight
you need to get out of there Knight you
need to find a new home get this pawn up
here so my bishop doesn't have to
babysit this pawn actually there's
connected passed pawns I just keep going
with this now I'll take this and then
push and then beef
oh I'm just dropping that let's get on
the light squares now change a plan 19
seconds late threat oh they missed that
back determine to 18 to 16 190 169 168
five minutes remaining qualifier whoo
qualifier alright I want to have some
space take this night away I'm not gonna
recapture I'm not sure how to explain it
are you gonna take that part yeah you
are yeah that can't be right that
definitely can't be right can it
alright this just needs to be smashed
open definitely needs to be smashed open
drop the Queen back at g6
all the way back looking for mate next
watch out the Queen's dead Queens cooked
my rook working okay it's still tough to
break down that light square bishop is
difficult to remove stop knight here
okay so much for that
okay new file has opened let's can test
it over here over here I need to get rid
of that night he is the glue he's the
glue of remove the glue and everything's
okay let's check he takes pawn with
check and guarding the rook let's just
do that
attack the pinned piece and now sneak my
king in how do you how do you win this
game oh I just come over here I was
thinking I can't even attack any pieces
I'm just gonna look for a mate next
right here on b4 dark squares dr.
charlie 238 236 what a tease 238 236 two
points I'd rather be down 20 points than
two points okay here we go
can I get a quick win this is there's
this game and just one more maybe this
game definitely in one more maybe
depending on how fast this game is come
on get h2h do exactly what I needed
exactly what I needed to 56 to 48 to 55
to 54 to 53 hang on I got a lead it took
forever took forever my goodness
whoa back to turn them in a boost oh man
what is this I'm getting showered with
points now Oh 276 276 - 32 minutes
thirty seconds left
okay I'm on f2 can I get an f2 again
aged two strikes again
age - hang on hang on each - again no
I'd be spoiled Oh what did I do it my
[ __ ] up my dark square Bishop is a fool
what a foolish foolish piece let's take
that before c5 slams the door in pieces
no slamming mean not even mean whoa hang
on dangerous stuff is right around the
corner
hang on are they trying something tricky
I could take the night with check take
the bishop
I get the night I still have mating
ideas oh my goodness I'm glad I'm I'll
slip there I'm so glad I mouse lift
right there how often do you say that
how often tell me whoa oh my goodness
take the night I guess you're gonna get
the night I got a play on time now yeah
I knew that was coming
how the Queens you come off hang on
maybe I take the pawn first with check I
want to hang out of the Queen actually
19 seconds I have to do pawn push I
don't really want to do that I want to
there's gonna be rookies for stuff now
if the knight Mose there's trouble stop
at 13 seconds 13 seconds if the knight
moves it's gonna be mate it's a fork get
the knight my rook is are protected who
cares about him though he's stupid over
here isn't he 13 seconds each pressure
on this where's the main threat they're
down in time oh no no no no what am i
doing attack to clean I want to give
check okay get the Queen's off I could
win this on time I got the rook over
here over here that's what it's a check
I get the bishop here no matter what
what's the clock what was it well day I
won I won I won
oh there it is just they could tie mine
oh man first-place confetti 270
oh there was a buzzer-beater they were
down on time and the clock just ran out
I think
where did they let that one finish
either way oh man
276 268 250 239 a very very tight pack
up here my goodness oh man good games ah
it's been a while since I did these
tournaments or when I'm streaming